-Our first guest tonight
is a talented actor
you know best as Sam Wilso
from the "Captain America"
and "Avengers" franchise,
as well as
the critically acclaimed
Disney+ series "The Falcon
and the Winter Soldier."
He can be seen next in "Solos,
which appears on
Amazon Prime Video on May 21st
Let's take a look.
-It's wrong.
-What?
-What? Really, what?
Look, everything, alright?
Everything is wrong.
-I read that every reunion
is different.
-Don't call it that.
-What do you want me
to call it, Tom?
-I don't know,
but it's not a reunion.
-Hmm.
-I shouldn't have called.
Alright?
I should have never called
-I wouldn't be here
if you hadn't called.
-That's what I'm saying.
My nose isn't...
Uh, I have a...
And your neck, it's all, like,
[Bleep ] necky.
-We're identical, Tom.
You think this is easy for m
to meet you for the first time
-Well, [Bleep] it must be
easy for you.
If you think you look like me,
it must be like
winning a [Bleep] jackpot.
-Please welcome back
to the show Anthony Mackie
How are you, Anthony?
-[ Chuckles ]
What's up, my man.
How is it going?
-I'm doing well.
So, we both have young kids.
And, look, I get it.
My kids aren't gonna
want to watch a show like this
But I assume --
you're in the superhero game -
that your kids would go craz
to watch your work.
And yet they're
not into the Marvel stuff.
-[ Chuckles ]
No, not at all.
We're a board-game family,
so I had to force them
to watch "The Falcon
and the Winter Soldier,"
because it's World War III
over here
when we play our board games
We've ripped up
many a Hungry Hungry Hippo
going at it over board games
But they got to see it.
-Hungry Hungry Hippos,
I'm just gonna say,
my wife's all-time
least-favorite game.
Like, marbles everywhere.
It's just a mess.
-It's a mess.
-She despises all those hippos
-And it's even worse
when you have to
continuously fix the hippos.
-Yeah.
-And then the dog
gets the hippos,
the dog chews the hippos,
you have to order a new one.
It's always a problem.
-I will say,
for as much as we play it,
when one of the hippos
gets broke,
I thought, at this point, it
would be better fixing them.
And every time, I feel lik
I'm starting at square one
-[ Laughs ] It's impossible.
We have Sebastian Stan
on the show,
and he said that neither of yo
really knew the extent to whic
"The Falcon and
the Winter Soldier"
was going to be a series,
but you ran into each othe
at the same hotel,
and based on that,
started to piece it together
-Yeah, we were --
And I had no idea where he was
because he lives in New York
I live in New Orleans.
So, I come down to the lobby
And I see him in the lobby
and I'm like, "Uh,
what are you doing here?"
He's like, "You have a meeting?"
I'm like, "Yeah.
You have a meeting?"
He's like, "Yeah."
Like, "Ah, you're gonna do it?
I'm like, "I don't know."
[ Laughs ]
It was, like, this amazing
Texas standoff
for about five minutes.
Then, we stood outside
waiting for our cars,
and neither one of us
said anything.
I was like, "Alright,
see you after your meeting."
He's like, "Yeah, you too.
[ Both laugh ]
-I know it's pointless to tr
to get any information
about "Captain America 4,"
which was just announced.
But this is interesting to me.
I assume someone like you
would find out
via some secret back channel
but you were actually
just in the supermarket
when you got word.
-Well, that's the funny thing.
I thought, being upgraded
to the suit and the shield
I would be the first guy
to get information,
you know, get a phone call
"Hey, Anthony.
This is what we're thinking.
What do you think?"
But I was literally --
When I go to the grocery store
I have my same guy that I go to,
and I've known him forever
And he'll close his line
until I get to the front.
And I just, like, go through
right?
So, I go up, and he's like
"Yo, is this real?"
And he had the announcemen
about "Cap 4" on his phone
But I still haven't heard
anything from Marvel.
I have no idea what's happening.
-[ Laughs ]
-As long as I know
I'm not fired, I'm happy.
-That was a clip we showed
from your new anthology
series, "Solos."
This obviously seems like
a nice change in tempo,
change in pace for you.
And it's sort of been --
being an anthology show,
it must feel a little bit more
like your theater roots
than playing the same characte
over a series of films.
-Oh, 100%, and
that's why I wanted to do it
This whole piece, "Solo," is
with Helen Mirren
and Morgan Freeman,
it's just such an amazing cast
Nicole Beharie.
And to get the opportunity
to play yourself
against yourself
is something a lot of actors
don't get the opportunity to do.
And it's such
an amazingly dramatic
but humbling experience.
So I was excited
to be a part of it,
'cause it was like doing a play.
It was 35 pages
of me running my mouth.
So, it was --
It was an experience.
-How did you enjoy
working with Anthony Mackie?
How was he --
-You know what? You know what?
I think I know why people
like me so much now.
I'm a pretty dope dude.
[ Both laughs ]
-Show up on time,
know your lines.
That's what everybody says
-Know your lines, everything
I'm not -- I always brough
myself something back
from craft service.
I gave myself notes on stuff
It was great, man.
I would do every movie with me
-Well, I hope you know
I'm not just blowing smoke
You guys have amazing chemistry.
-[ Laughs ]
-The two Anthony Mackies,
just absolutely amazing.
-No, we had
a great time together.
There's nothing like
answering yourself
when you're talking to yourself.
-[ Laughs ]
-You -- I read -- And again,
like I said,
I know you have a background -
a theater school background,
that you will still go bac
and read Shakespeare
for pleasure and relaxation.
-Yeah, that's my thing.
You know, with good jobs,
you get gifts from
your agents and managers.
So, you know, I got,
like, the first folio.
I got the original edition
I got all these
different editions.
So, it's interesting to see,
you know, the difference
every time a new edition
came out
and how those words would change
the meaning of
a monologue or a play.
So, I always go back
just to keep up on it,
'cause you never know
when you're gonna get
that phone call.
You know,
"Shakespeare in the Park, man.
You got to prepare --
That's a lifelong preparation.
You know?
-I'm heartbroken
to tell you this.
The other Anthony Mackie got it.
-[ Laughs ]
-Hey, to be
a true New York actor,
you have to do "Law & Order"
and you have to do
Shakespeare in the Park.
That's the two requirements.
-If you can tick
those two boxes.
How young were you
the first time you Shakespeare
-The first time
I did Shakespeare,
I was in ninth grade,
so I was 14.
I was 14 years old.
My teacher, Ray Frizell,
gave me a play to read,
and I was --
I went to public school
in New Orleans at the time
when New Orleans was
the worse place on Earth.
The teachers were more about
keeping kids in school
than introducing them to stuff
And this one teacher
really just opened my eyes
to the world of literature
and introduced me
to Ibsen and Chekhov
and all these different
aspects of culture
that I had never heard of.
And Shakespeare --
I was blown away
that this white dude
500 years ago
could write a play
that I could relate to today
-You mentioned
you were in New Orleans.
And we have talked about
being NFL fans
in some of your recent visits.
-[ Laughs ]
-And you -- I mean, I gues
one of the downsides
of being a Saints fan is,
they're so good
that they never really hav
a particularly high draft pick
But did you enjoy their draft,
as it were?
-You know what?
I will say --
And I give --
If nothing else fails,
we have the smartest draft
selections out of everybody.
If they just rate everybod
on their GPAs,
we literally broke the --
we have --
we drafted
a whole team of accountants.
[ Both laugh ]
I'm very happy about the dudes
that we drafted.
We have a damn good lineup
this year.
-That's good.
I wish you the best of luck.
Thank you so much
for being here, Anthony.
And congrats on everything
-Thanks a lot.
Good to see you, man.
-Good to see you, too.
"Solos" premieres
on Amazon Prime Video
on Friday, May 21st.